well the the lecture this evening is
about the world candidates tournament I
believe today they had the opening
ceremony and cantonments ensk Siberia
Russia and the players it's going to be
an eight-player double round-robin the
winner of this tournament is going to be
the Challenger two world champion Magnus
Carlsen so the eight best players in the
world are going to compete against one
another both having black and white
against one another so it's a fourteen
round tournament fourteen games of top
top-level chess and we know that in the
tournament is Levon Aronian the world's
number two ranked player of Lattimore
kramnik the world's number three ranked
player Veselin Topalov the world's
number four ranked player and so forth
and so on and those hopefully everybody
knows about the tournament please yes
good good good good I have three
favorites in the tournament I see Levon
Aronian Vladimir Kramnik Veselin Topalov
who happened to be the highest rated
players in the field as being the
favorites that doesn't mean that a
dark-horse a Peter Svidler Shakir
Mahmoud are of a odd Dracon andreia they
can will not win it it just means that
they're not my pre-tournament favourites
in the previous candidates tournament it
came down to a two-person race between
Vladimir Kramnik and Magnus Carlsen
going into the last round these two
players Magnus Carlsen and Vladimir
Kramnik had the same number
points Vladimir Kramnik was going to
play black against his Ukrainian rival
vasily von Schuch magnus carlsen had
white against Peter Svidler Vladimir
Kramnik was in in distress because
essentially having black against a
genius like Yvonne Chuck was no fun to
begin with
and secondly uhm Kramnik if he drew that
game could expect that Magnus would
either win with white or draw with white
okay so Kramnik was in a strange
situation if he plays solidly against
Vasily von Schaack and makes a draw and
if magnus carlsen plays solidly against
Peter Svidler and makes a draw then they
again they would be tied but the rules
of the tiebreaker said that in case of a
tie in this particular case because of
the complicated tie breaking procedures
Magnus Carlsen would qualify and play
against the swan Athan Anand for the
World Chess Championship match
okay so Vladimir Kramnik had to go all
out for the win with black long story
short he ended up losing the game Magnus
Carlsen with white he ended up losing
this game that we're about to see so the
two players who were leading the
tournament going into the last round
both lost their games Magnus Carlsen
Vladimir Kramnik ended up with an equal
number of points Magnus Carlsen had the
higher tie breaker Magnus Carlsen went
on to play against Anand and won the
world championship match and hence today
Magnus Carlsen is the world champion
so was it nerves what happened
that Magnus literally backed his way
into a challenger and will we see this
type of fighting chess and crazy results
going on in continent since this year it
will be an exciting event in anyway
going down memory lane for a moment this
tournament is literally a year old it
was played in March of 2013 the
candidates tournament now against efore
Peter Svidler has a pretty narrow
repertoire and he's long defended the
black side of the Spanish so if Magnus
was going to play
efore he could expect that he was going
to get a rule Lopez defense on the board
so let's see how the game and castles
and the players pretty much got a
standard position now here once again
you can't go immediately for this trade
of Knight and Bishop because this pawn
lacks protection so essentially Spindler
did do what you wanted to do only he
didn't go hunting down the bishop on B 3
d6
a3 so now as Michael so nicely pointed
out with this pawn protected white was
concerned that night a5 would end up
capturing his bishop so with this move
a3 what Magnus wanted to do was give
himself an opportunity to retreat his
Bishop to a - yes yes the other I would
I would I would certainly suggest that
this move c2 c3 is far more common than
a three so the idea of c3 is that after
the knight chases the bishop the bishop
might come back to c2 Magnus is
reasoning is that okay the bishop is
okay on c2 but
maybe it would even be better on this
diagonal in the argument in favor of the
move c3 is that it supports White's
eventual occupation of the centre with
default so let's see castles Knight c3
very logical move what white is thinking
is that this square on d5
makes a nice launching pad a nice
outpost and this night could also if it
wants swing over to g3 and to f5 okay
Bishop b7 black decides that even though
he reckoned black recognizes that this
Bishop on b3 is on a very good diagonal
black reckons that he's not interested
in the move Bishop d5 in Bishop e6
pardon me trying to trade bishops but
instead goes for his own idea of Bishop
b7 so let's see how the game went Bishop
d2 a rather quiet move black part of me
white is just getting again getting his
pieces out Queen d7 a4 and now a change
of tactic strategically a change of
plans by white I had expected that white
might go for Knight e 2 followed by 93
with the idea of bringing his Knight to
f5 and I had not expected Magnus to play
the move a4 but what Magnus is reasoning
is is that hey listen if you let me I'm
going to take that pawn trade rooks and
take this pawn with my knight if you
advance your pawn to b4 then I'm going
to jump to d5 and thanks to my bishop on
D - I'm going to put pressure on your
advanced beep on Peter said ok I
understand if my pawn goes to b4 it will
be weak I'll drop my knight back
I'll protect my pawn with the Queen and
I'm hoping that I is black will be able
to play Knight to e6 and jump to f4 one
day a Bab rook e8 bishop a so a trade of
rooks and neither side has really
benefited from that trade of rooks just
it's an equal look swap 92 well here
goes Magnus trying to reposition is
Knight 96 Knight g3 so we can kind of
sum up the opening somewhat in the sense
that I think both players can be
satisfied from from a practical point of
view black has no real targets in this
position no real weaknesses this Knight
can play Knight c5 or perhaps one day
Knight d4 to try to harass the bishop or
the knight could go to f4 from whites
point of view this night could
potentially go to f5 and try to capture
a bishop so basically a very balanced
position c5 now this introduces a
different dynamic what black is trying
to say with this move as you see my
bishop on B it's kind of hitting on
granite at the moment this pawn is very
well supported
but if black could play the move C 5 c4
then after captures this pawn will be
vulnerable and this Bishop will be on an
excellent diagonal so with the move C 5
C 4 are meet with the move c5 black is
angling for c4 Knight f5 stepping up
going after the bishop on e7 Bishop
steps back to d8 and again different
attacking themes are now coming into
focus this Bishop is no great shakes on
the d8 square that's for sure but black
is thinking look I want to play c4
and I want to put my bishop on this
diagonal against black White's King and
hey who's attacking whom and why who
stands worse I don't think there is
anything wrong with the movement Peter
Svidler played Bishop d8 I had just
expected him having said a to continue
by saying be what Peter why Peter may
not have played this move I'm not sure
is he may have felt that for example
something like tanks take oh sorry I did
that wrong that was a muscle it don't
add tags no that's not what I want
takes takes takes over right wears a
overweight yeah takes takes takes tanks
he may have felt that in this position
white had some edge thanks to his two
bishops let's say a move like Bishop b5
he may have been concerned about but I
really don't see this as much of a
problem in the first place d6 is really
defended very very well and in the
second place thanks to this open
diagonal for the bishop ideas like Queen
b7 start to be very attractive for for
black let me just show you one idea
the knight is threatening to play - D -
G - when there is a massive attack on
this diagonal but that was not Peters
choice and what he did was certainly
okay I just expected him to continue
with his ID of C 5 C 4 he played Bishop
d8 Magnus stopped black from playing C 4
takes takes now as a result of this
exchange the pawn structures changed and
this pawn is a little bit weak this pawn
is okay this pawn a little bit backward
but what was really happened is that
this Bishop is actually now very passive
even if it were to move to the square d6
it would not be on an active diagonal so
I think overall this trade of what's
happened on the Queen side has
benefitted white bishop c7 rook e1 rook
e8 Queen c1 this is an interesting
little move by Magnus this move Queen c1
what Magnus is saying with this move is
what he wants to do is play his Knight
to g5 or even potentially his Bishop to
h6
if the bishop is captured the Queen
could recapture and there would be a
sudden attack on blacks King so I
thought this little little nuance shift
by Magnus was was a little cheeky I I
might say and quite effective sometimes
the simplest moves are best 9 h5 so what
was the idea here with this move Peter
Peter saying well Bishop h6 I can deal
with that by just advancing my pawn I
don't even have to capture the bishop
but it's also ambitious black is saying
hey there's no reason why I shouldn't
put my knight on an
excellent square F for g3 I agree with
you I don't want you to put your knight
on h4 g6 I don't like your knight on f5
either check King g7 and now things are
really starting to heat up and it's not
a hundred percent clear to anyone and I
remember being literally glued to my
monitor watching these game with this
game unfold because it was so critical
to the World Championship title suddenly
there's a lot of ideas
thanks to this pawn coming to g3 Black
has a lot of ambitions of sliding as
Queen over to the h3g Foursquare ideas
like Knight takes f7 Queen takes f7
Knight g5 combinations like like that
are in the air and I wasn't sure was the
knight well placed on h6
or offsides Knight comes to g5 okay with
this Knight jump to the g5 square the
pawn on f7 is attacked twice and black
has to do something about that you
traded Knights and played the move d65
sorry before black played the move d65
obviously the bishop on c4 and the
knight on H 6 are both attacking this
pawn Peter had the possibility of
playing f7 f6 attacking the bishop
perhaps forcing the bishop to return and
then playing d5 but beter like his pawns
around his king where they are and he
played the move d fine and this is sort
of well what we kind of call on or on
Henry HLN ery on re resistance I mean
with this move what Peter's trying to do
is open up this day
and after all whites King is also
exposed pawn takes Bishop takes Knight
g4 so this is a tricky move at first
sight it appears that Queen takes you
put your knight under attack but then
the bishop takes recaptures on d5 if you
play Bishop takes d5 Queen takes d5
protects the knight and also this Bishop
is trying to angle to try to get it
blacks King maybe Bishop h6 check or do
you see this this Q tactic let's let's
make a terrible move for black for a
second what's a bad move this is a bad
move good I knew I could find one Bishop
f6 check blue with the idea Knight takes
Queen check ooh
and then ouch
Knight takes f6 and there's the
checkmate on h7 the Knight attacks the
Queen and black is lost so definitely
black has to be very very careful
so Peter played Bishop f3 attacking the
knight Magnus played Bishop f6 check
King drop back to g8 the knight is
hanging Knight h6 check King f8 and with
this wild position crazy things are
going on black stream is to play Queen
h3 in Queen G to checkmate
White's dream is to capture all kinds of
pawns and blacks position this pawn on
it
seven this pawn on c5 well at the same
time staving off
checkmate against his own king queen III
attacks the bishop on f3 attacks the
pawn on c5 and both players were getting
into serious what we call Zeit not or
time trouble that is to say they had a
little time on the clock in a very wild
position Bishop dropped back to b7 and
Bishop dropped back to h4 it's
absolutely crazy in this position the
computers were all saying that white had
a very big advantage by a crazy move
that frankly many human players most
human players would not consider this
Bishop on f6 is under threat to this
night on h5 so Magnus could consider
capturing this pawn sacrificing his
Bishop to get this rook or he could
consider moving this bishop he decided
to retreat the bishop to h4 it turns out
that according to the computer that if
if Magnus had found the move Bishop h8
he's actually doing very well he's
winning the game it's a crate but
whoever thought of putting their bishop
on h8 as a way of being and safety
the reality is thanks to the night on h6
there's no King g8 and you're not going
to king e7 to attack the bishop because
the pawn is hanging on e5 in the
meanwhile you have to defend this pawn
on f7 as well as the pawn on c5 Michael
no as it turns out he had actually
played it accurately it was only in this
position that he didn't find the move
Bishop h8 that would be the cause of his
downfall so what he did he actually
played a really really good game and it
was at this critical juncture that he
has missed Bishop h8 and of course as
Peter confessed happily confessed after
the game as well he didn't consider that
move either
yeah but sure okay oops
I beg your pardon so with the bishop
going to h8 so okay so essentially black
is facing two very distinct and direct
threats the first one is this pawn is
hanging and it can be captured either if
it's captured by the knight that would
open up a possibility of Queen check and
the second threat that white has is also
to snapple this pawn on c5 so it's
considered that this move Queen c6
defending the pawn on c5 while
simultaneously introducing a new threat
of Queen g2 checkmate would have been
black best move now White has to decide
how he wants to deal with this threat
he can do it one of two ways he could
block with his queen with Queen e4 or he
could play the move f2 f3 it was
considered when the players analyzed the
game in hindsight that f3 was White's
best play and here black has to do
something about this pawn on f7 and they
were reckoning that the pawn would move
f 6 what would happen here after
anybody's guess it's just a crazy weird
position that anything but standard
let's go back and this Bishop h4 Queen
h3 well that was a that wasn't an
uninvited guest
I'm sure Magnus had anticipated this
move because it does threaten checkmate
after all that he was more likely
expecting that the Queen was going to
come to c6 not to h3 f3 blocking the
threat this is a guy who's not being
denied huh Knight f4 so now a new threat
of Queen G to check up here's captures
Knight captures the bishop Knight
captures f7 now again in this moment the
time the time pressure on both players
was really fierce and here something was
going wrong for Magnus here's here's
where the game starts to go south in a
hurry and I think that this was
considered culprit for that okay so
first of all it's pretty clear that we
can't go Queen takes e5 check and go
after this Bishop because our rook is
hanging okay it's pretty clear our
knight is under duress so I think it was
Knight g4 that was this was the move
that
I think people had expected that the
chess engines that are all convinced us
that this was the best move by white
obviously this pawn is the it's the
center of attention as is this pawn
White's King is dodgy but those blacks
King and somehow Magnus thought that
Knight takes f7 was a very strong move
realizing of course that pawn takes f4
would allow Queen takes e8 winning in
short order this move he has missed
Bishop takes f3 and suddenly oops this
pawn a very very very important pawn in
White's camp the bishop can't be
captured because of the threat of Queen
takes and in the meanwhile Black is
threatening Queen g4 check and once
again Queen g2 so Magnus suddenly under
a lot of pressure queen f2 his idea is
that after queen g4 check he can block
and save his king
pawn takes e4 a moment ago there was a
pin along the e-file
when the Queen was here but now that the
queen is in a defensive position there
was no reason for black not to capture
this pawn and in fact after that
happened boom just like that it's game
over Magnus is in the losing ending one
two three pawns one two three four pawns
for black furthermore Black has the two
bishops giving him an edge as well the
final moves of the game were 95
and now we see what's happening it's
simple like it's just going push push
push push
and queening it was strange because on
the other game between Vladimir von
Schaack and Vladimir Kramnik and
Vasilyev on shot their position had also
gone into a time trouble situation and
at the end of that time trouble kramnik
realized he was losing and and through
most of his game he had avoided making a
draw so then he suddenly woke up to this
horrible realization a damn if I just
made a draw I would have been the one
playing vision on for the World
Championship and this was the final I
think Magnus resigned hearing calyxes so
very very exciting
tournament again the most exciting
tournament in the last decade that I can
recall